diese Tomatensuppe kriegen ihre
Cremigkeit durch Toastbrot und ist
deshalb sogar vegan und das ist alles
was wir brauchen Dosentomaten eine
gehackte Zwiebel zwei geriebene
Knoblauchzehen Oregano weißes Toastbrot
und Olivenöl davon gehen wir ein
bisschen was in unseren Topf und sobald
es warm ist geben wir unsere Zwiebeln
dazu und das ist genau jetzt wir geben
die Zwiebeln hinein und Dünsten die ein
bisschen glasig sind jetzt gehen wir
unseren geriebenen Knoblauch dazu
Oregano dazu so alles einmal schön
aromatisieren in der Zwischenzeit bereit
und schneiden einfach die Ränder ab das
Essen wir einfach
und jetzt gehen wir unsere Dosentomaten
dazu das sind 800 Gramm Suppe ist
aufgekocht jetzt nehmen wir uns unseren
Mixer dafür füllen wir jetzt unsere
Suppe ein und jetzt noch die Geheimzutat
Toastbrot gehen wir hinzu und das
wirklich krass dieses Toastbrot ersetzt
ein halben Liter Sahne habe ich das
Gefühl weil die Suppe wird super cremig
und wir starten den Mixer wenn das Ganze
gut durchgemixt ist machen wir den noch
mal auf niedriger Stufe an und
Immobilien mit Olivenöl nicht vergessen
das ganze ein bisschen zu salzigen und
wir können servieren gehen Sie einfach
einen Suppenteller so einen schönen
Kringel Olivenöl schwarzer Pfeffer